>>> TODAY IS THE DAY THAT MANY
WALL STREET FIRMS HAVE TARGETED
FOR EMPLOYEES TO RETURN TO THE
OFFICE FULL TIME BUT THAT'S NOT
WHAT SOME WORKERS WANT.
CNN'S VANESSA YURKEVICH IS HERE.
>> ABSOLUTELY, JOHN, COMPANIES
ARE LOOKING TO GET EMPLOYEES
BACK IN THE OFFICE.
THEY WANT TO HAVE MORE OVERSIGHT
OVER WORKERS AND THEY WANT TO
JUSTIFY THE MILLIONS IN SQUARE
FEET OF OFFICE SPACE THEY'RE
PAYING FOR.
>> Reporter: A FIVE-DAY WORK
WEEK IS NOTHING NEW.
BUT POST-PANDEMIC, FIVE DAYS IN
THE OFFICE CAN FEEL
OVERWHELMING.
POST-LABOR DAY, SOME COMPANIES
ARE NOW REQUIRING EMPLOYEES TO
HANG UP THEIR HOUSE SLIPPERS AND
GET BACK IN THE OFFICE FOR GOOD.
WHAT WOULD YOUR IMMEDIATE
REACTION BE TO THAT?
>> I GO, NO.
>> Reporter: IT'S A FEELING MANY
AMERICANS MAY BE HAVING, 56% OF
FULL-TIME U.S. EMPLOYEES, MORE
THAN 70 MILLION WORKERS, SAY
THEY CAN DO THEIR JOB FROM HOME.
BUT COMPANIES LIKE GOLDMAN
SACHS, TESLA, BANK OF AMERICA
AND MORGAN STANLEY ARE REQUIRING
EMPLOYEES TO RETURN TO THE
OFFICE FULL TIME.
>> THEY'RE FEELING VERY
CONFIDENT ABOUT, YOU KNOW, IT'S
BACK TO SCHOOL.
IT'S BACK TO THE OFFICE, IT'S
BACK TO REALITY.
>> Reporter: ABOUT 6.5% OF
EMPLOYEES IN THE U.S. WERE
TELEWORKING LAST MONTH.
FEWER THAN IN JULY.
A SIGN THAT SOME WORKERS COULD
BE GETTING CALLED BACK IN.
FOR ATTORNEY JESSICA CARROLL THE
PROSPECT OF GOING INTO THE
OFFICE FULL TIME AGAIN WOULD BE
A CHALLENGE.
>> YOU'VE KIND OF GOTTEN USED TO
THIS HYBRID WORK FROM HOME
EXPERIENCE.
IT WOULD BE HARD TO JUST GO FROM
WHAT IT IS NOW TO FIVE DAYS.
KIND OF LIKE RIPPING OFF A
BAND-AID.
>> Reporter: LIKE MOST, CARROLL
WAS IN THE OFFICE EVERY DAY IN
2020.
>> IT WAS PRETTY DEMANDING.
>> Reporter: THEN COVID HIT.
SHE HAD A NEWBORN AND CHANGED
JOBS.
A HYBRID SCHEDULE WAS IMPORTANT
WHERE SHE COULD BE ON A
CONFERENCE CALL AND STILL PICK
UP HER OLDER KIDS AFTER SCHOOL.
THE MOTHER OF THREE SAYS SO FAR
HER NEW FIRM HAS BEEN FLEXIBLE.
>> HAVING PEOPLE IN THE OFFICE
AND MORE AVAILABLE BY PERSON,
RATHER THAN BY PHONE, IT'S
SOMETHING THAT THEY ENCOURAGE.
BUT THERE'S NO STRICT POLICY.
>> Reporter: AFTER TWO YEARS
WORKING FROM HOME, SOME
COMPANIES HAVE FULLY EMBRACED
IT.
THIS SUMMER, YELP ANNOUNCED IT
WOULD CLOSE OFFICES IN THREE
MAJOR CITIES AFTER JUST 1% OF
EMPLOYEES VOLUNTARILY RETURNED
IN PERSON.
BUT SOME JOBS CAN'T BE DONE
REMOTELY.
>> THERE ARE MOMENTS IN OUR WORK
WHERE IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
BE IN PERSON.
>> Reporter: BOTTOM LINE IS A
NOT FOR PROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
HELPS LOWER INCOME HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS GET INTO COLLEGE.
80% OF ITS 140 EMPLOYEES HAVE
IN-PERSON JOBS AND STARTED THEIR
RETURN TO OFFICE THIS SUMMER.
DID YOU FACE ANY RESISTANCE FROM
STAFF?
>> I THINK THERE WAS TREPIDATION
ACROSS THE BOARD.
>> DID YOU LOSE ANYBODY ALONG
THE WAY?
>> I'M SURE WE LOST A FEW FOR
THEM THE DECISION TO BE BACK IN
THE OFFICE WASN'T THE RIGHT
DECISION.
>> Reporter: WITH OVER 11
MILLION UNFILLED JOBS THAT'S
ABOUT TWO OPEN POSITIONS FOR
EVERY JOB SEEKER A
RETURN-TO-OFFICE MANDATE COULD
BE A DEAL BREAKER.
BOTTOM LINE HAS 15 IN-PERSON
ROLES TO FILL.
>> WE HAVEN'T BEEN IMMUNE TO THE
GREAT RESIGNATION.
WE'VE SEEN HIGHER TURNOVER IN
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS.
IT ABSOLUTELY IS A CONCERN.
>> 60% OF ALL EMPLOYEES WHO ARE
WORKING FROM HOME SAY THAT IF
THEIR EMPLOYER SAID THEY HAD TO
COME BACK IN THE OFFICE, THEY
WOULD ACTUALLY SWITCH JOBS.
THAT'S ACCORDING TO A GALLUP
POLL, AND COMPANIES ARE MAKING
THE PUSH TO GET PEOPLE BACK IN
THE OFFICE MORE SO AROUND THE
EAST COACH AND MAJOR CITIES,
THAT'S BECAUSE THE COMMUTE TIME
INTO THE OFFICE ARE A LOT
LONGER.
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER FOLKS USED
TO COMMUTING FROM THEIR BEDROOM.
STOPPING FOR COFFEE IN THE
KITCHEN AND GOING TO THEIR DESK
AND WORKING FROM HOME.
THIS IS SOMETHING, JOHN, WE'LL
SEE PLAY OUT OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE YEARS.
THIS IS CERTAINLY NOT THE LAST
SHOWDOWN BETWEEN EMPLOYERS AND
EMPLOYEES.
>> THERE'S A LOT LESS TRAFFIC ON
THE WAY FROM THE BEDROOM TO THE
COFFEEMAKER.
LOOK, WE'LL SEE THE FREE MARKET
PLAY OUT.
WE'LL SEE VERY SOON WHO HAS THE
LEVERAGE, WHETHER THE WORKERS OR
EMPLOYERS.
VANESSA YURKEVICH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.